it's great to be joined today by Neil
Howe who is an author demographer
managing director of demography at hedge
eye risk management and the man who
coined the term millennial you may also
recognize his last name from Strauss how
generational theory and we'll talk about
how that connects to some modern
political happenings as well Neil it's
so great to have you on and I appreciate
you taking the time to talk to me today
thank you it's it's wonderful to be here
so let's talk a little bit about Strauss
how generational theory for people who
may be uninitiated in that generally
speaking when did you start researching
that and how did you develop that theory
we started working on this in the late
1980s we did a very large book project
really retelling all of American history
from the 17th century on our from the
viewpoint of separate kind of collective
generational biographies and that book
was published in in 1991 that was called
generations the history of America's
future
we did another book on Generation X and
then in 1997 we did a book called the
fourth turning which revisits
generational theory but looks at it a
little bit more explicitly in terms of
social and political and cultural cycles
generated by this this sort of you know
collective biographical change and that
that is probably the book that people
you know remember most in terms of
predictions we made about where America
is going and and for that matter much of
the world and it's based on the idea of
for roughly 20 years stages that recur
in a sort of cyclical way can you talk
to us a little bit about the four stages
yes they're there for different kinds of
generations we call them archetypes and
you know some like like boomers I think
all Americans today familiar with them
are born right after crises indulgently
raised and they come of age with the
Great Awakenings of American history
these great kind of cataclysmic and and
often somewhat somewhat violent or
acrimonious
brakes in our culture and values and
then there are other types of
generations like what we call the hero
archetype which is you know protectively
raised right after an awakening and
typically comes of age during the great
crises of our history but but it's
interesting that American history has
these regular rhythms of kind of times
when we make the inner world and remake
the outer world the great political and
civic crises of our history have all
been separated by about the length of a
long human life about 80 or 90 years and
roughly in between halfway in between we
have the great kind of cultural
upheavals the remaking of our inner
world the Great Awakenings you know we
used to even number them you know first
Great Awakening Second Great Awakening
third and so on and and that gives rise
to a alternating series of kind of
seasons of history first turning when
institutions are strong individualism as
weak society feels a great sense of you
know collective momentum toward the
future and then the second turnings are
the Great Awakenings when people tire of
all the social discipline and the
conformity and try to refine themselves
these are the great individualizing
periods of our history the third turning
when institutions is discredited
individualism is flourishing government
you know there's we enjoy periods of
weak government weak regulation these
are these are the great periods of sort
of free agency in American history often
periods a very high immigration and then
ultimately the this concludes with a
kind of a winter season if you will of
crisis of outer world change this is
when we kind of tear down and rebuild
the realm of politics economy and Empire
and these are the these are often
periods of total war in American history
how far back does this for cycle for
stage cycle fit into American history
well in actually in the in the fourth
turning we take it all the way back to
the late Middle Ages with sort of Anglo
American history in generations we
really started with
sort of the the Armada crisis which came
right before they you know the the epic
confrontation between England and Spain
which happened just before the Puritan
generation was born who actually you
know constituted the great migration to
New England in the 1630s but ever since
then and you know we've had we've had
the the probably the first great global
war in Western history was the word of
Spanish Succession and the Glorious
Revolution in England which certainly
involved the colonies lifetime after
that we had the American Revolution and
lifetime after that we had the civil war
we had World War two and and and in the
and the Great Depression and and now
here we are
so we'll get to Stephen Bannen in a bit
but before that I'd be curious to hear
from you you depending on what you read
you see that there are some who tend to
be more social conservatives who
evaluate your theory and say oh that
means we might be getting close to sort
of getting back to the social
conservatism of the 40s and 50s and then
you also see some liberals who will
interpret your theory and say oh we
might be getting ready to move away from
the sort of Reagan Bush deregulation and
get back into something that will appeal
more to social progressives where do you
assess that we are right now I assess
that that you could interpret it either
way because in fact these these fourth
turnings tend to be accompanied by by a
kind of a traditional ism or classicism
or if you want to define a conservatism
the culture but definitely toward a
movement it left or in the populist or
authoritarian direction in the economy
so you know depending on your politics
you could be on the left or on the right
and either look favorably on this or or
not fourth turnings tend to redefine
what we mean by left and right and I
think part of that redefinition is
already going on today particularly
since the last election well to talk
about that a little bit I mean I guess
to get us into the entire Steve Bannon
thing for people who don't know
Steve ban and I guess is a sort of a
scholar or student of your theory
although not not a personal student of
yours as I'm sure you'll tell us how did
you first come to know that Strauss how
generational theory was of interest to
Steven Bannon I I don't know it goes
back many years I think he Proust
contacted us maybe
eight or nine or ten years ago I didn't
know who he was so I don't think I ever
got back to him he was it was but he was
a it was a film director in LA and I
think what people don't realize is that
since his Goldman's sac days he's
goldman sachs days he's really been
involved in entertainment the media i
mean that's really what interests him a
direction in the pop culture he's not
primarily oriented around political
principle or religion he has a he has he
has a flair or a an instinct for where
the culture is going and he particularly
as its interpreted through entertainment
videogames media and so forth but anyway
he later on did a documentary called
generation zero which I agreed to
participate in a bit I thought it was an
interesting thesis and and and he's done
a fair amount of directing since then
and I've I've you know met with him a
number of times on that is your sense
that the way in which his interpretation
of your theory as it applies to thinking
about how he advised the Trump campaign
is it true in some way to how you
develop this do you see it as a
departure or perversion or
misinterpretation of your theory I mean
what are your thoughts now that we know
that this was so has so informed how he
has sort of entered politics over the
last years it's definitely a
sensationalization or popularization of
what we did there's no question about
that but but it's interesting that his
loyalty as undoubtedly you know since
you've been following him is not really
to the Trump administration and he said
that several times he does
really care where Trump is going he he
is dedicated to the formation of this
new populist movement this populist
party if the GOP is a good vehicle for
that then fine he thinks that's you know
a good bet for him now but if it isn't
he'll find some other way to do it so I
guess I guess what I mean to say about
that is he's not looking at this as a
tool to revitalize the GOP I don't
really honestly don't think he cares too
much about what happens to the
Republican Party well aside from viewing
it as a tool I mean can it even really
be a tool in the sense that if there are
these roughly four 20 year periods that
lead to a single eighty year cycle if
that is some sort of natural place that
society settles in Kent can you really
do anything about that in other words
would knowledge of that really allow you
to change the course of that or do you
believe that that's just the natural
course of things regardless of people's
awareness of it or not well it's
interesting if you if you view history
as being in some respects or in some
aspects of its cyclical and and by the
way this was the ancient belief you know
before the rise of monotheistic religion
and so on all traditional societies all
pre-modern societies saw time is
basically cyclical and you didn't try to
change it you tried to perform well
within it and I think that actually
gives you a good guide as to as to as I
better look back on history it's not so
much that you can avoid the turnings you
can't suddenly try to imagine that The
Awakening isn't going to happen or that
a fourth turning mood will not happen I
think then what you focus on in terms of
your own choices how do you make this
end well right how does every actor play
their roles well so that it ends most
happily and productively and fruitfully
for all involved as opposed to being a
truly horrible and destructive Cataclysm
which all of us want to avoid what would
you see today as sort of a key
distinguishing a key distinguisher
between the
and following generation and the older
generations within the sort of a
political economy I guess I would say in
the way that it would impact elections
is there some key difference other than
just age and interests for example or
how they choose to spend their money the
simple stuff that we read articles about
all the time that you think really
distinguishes the younger generations
from the older generations alive today
well one of the things we see with
Millennials and by the way this is not
just here in the United States this is
in Britain this is in Europe and this is
in East Asia you see this is an
attraction to sort of one size fits all
solutions kind of populist /
authoritarian solutions which remake
institutions which work well for their
future it's interesting today in in in
Southeast Asia for example you see the
young hugely supporting these new
charismatic authoritarian populist
leaders like Narendra Modi and India Xi
Jinping in China Shinzo Abe a and in
Britain and in in Japan
and Rodrigo Duterte in the Philippines
all of these leaders were
disproportionately favored by young
people I mean young Filipinos have voted
in to tear take young young Chinese now
are usually supportive of Xi Jinping
they're all trying to get into the
Communist Party where it's 20 years ago
they weren't you see that too and all of
these leaders by the way are trying to
orient their new definition of
nationalism around the kind of the main
cultural social religious mainstream of
their country you look at Europe right
now with the new identity Rhian movement
you know we've gone from identity
politics in the 60s to identitarian ism
in in in in in that in 2010s and I think
that's a telling shift and we see in in
America where Millennials were hugely in
favor of you know on the here and you
hear you see it on the Left which was
Bernie Sanders as well as in you know
that jeremy corbyn in the UK you've got
an absolutely epic shift toward young
voters only
said I think we should make tuition free
and invest hugely in infrastructure
here's the problem is that Millennials
around the world they're looking
particularly in liberal democracies they
are seeing older individualistic leaders
like boomers fail at the basic tasks of
governance
they have no focus on the future they're
not even discussing much less coming to
terms with any issue that affects their
you know their long-term prospects
another interesting figment of this or
another outgrowth of this and if you
look at P at Millennials around the
world what they think of China right now
older people when you ask them there's a
Pew study that really documents this
well older people think well China they
really don't approve of it it's an
authoritarian regime they they crush
dissidents and so on we think that's bad
the Millennials around the world thinks
China's pretty neat I mean they invest
you know 40 percent of the national
income in the future they're building
250 mile an hour bullet trains you know
they they make the trains run on time
and they you know it's kind of that's
because society that works so here's
what I see and people sometimes ask me
how do you know that a society is moving
from a you know post-war mood to a
pre-war mood right and that's kind of
hard to tell before there's another war
or before another Christ Civic crisis of
some kind I would say a good clue is to
the respective attitudes of young and
old adult institutional Authority and
social order in a post-war era it's the
old people who actually just went
through the Civic crisis who are
supportive of civic order and it's the
young people that resent it who you know
rebel against it and so forth and of
course that's what we had earlier in the
post you know world war ii era you know
you're going to a pre-war era when the
older people are the you know great
defenders of libertarianism and
individualism and everyone's you know
right to due process and sort of
basically sealing off their rights or
their entitlements to whatever wealth
and power older people are enjoying and
it's the younger people who become more
in favor of government strong government
actually works get things done and
actually you know shifts things more in
their direction that is to say toward
the future and I think that's where we
beginning to see around much of the
world today it's manifesting itself on
the left or on the right depending on
which country you look at we've been
speaking with the Neil Howe he is an
author demographer managing director of
demography at hedge eye risk management
Neil thanks so much for talking to me
today you're welcome